[Music]
that dad I'm [ __ ] sick Donna and I'm
really [ __ ] sick now so let's all make
a [ __ ] video that's about cringe and
Christmas it's the second day of
Christmas I hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I am really sick like I
don't know why every time I get sick I
get in my throat just dist absolutely
revolt against my body and then decides
to explode in a fireball of death but
that's what happens so I would show you
a picture of the back of my mouth but
that'd be [ __ ] disgusting you know
what [ __ ] it here we go there it is
whoop if you missed it oh well delay
it's gone [ __ ] I don't know I had to
take a picture of my mouth I could just
take a picture of somebody else's
fucked-up throat but it's bad it's no
good but that's authentic 100%
markiplier right there because I don't
care right now anyway hello everybody my
name is markiplier welcome to try not to
cringe version 2 I don't know why I keep
doing try not to cringes when I'm sick
it's not an intentional thing but I
swear I planned this because we just did
the cringe Minh special charity
livestream with Felix Jack Emma and PJ
and everybody else had joined along and
it was cringe miss so I thought that I
would do another try not to cringe for
Christmas and it just so [ __ ]
happened that I was sick during it it's
not my fault if you think I'm faking it
smash that like button why you know this
oh [ __ ] men oh my sweet baby I think we
got christmas-themed cold medicine clear
and cool just like Christmas what you
don't think that's [ __ ] Christmas
[ __ ] me then oh are you cringing already
is it already time for the cringe if
you've cringed already [ __ ] smash
that like button if you're in the
Christmas spirit [ __ ] destroy that
like button if you're not [ __ ] smash
that like button and we did 1 million
likes on this vitamin C [ __ ] it's good
for you where's dick oh well my beer
well [ __ ] it
as if I care if you don't care [ __ ]
check that goddamn like button in the
face like a goddamn boss sideswipe that
[ __ ] like button [ __ ] oh man I'm
using up all my energy on this intro
it's not a good idea
who's ready for the cringe because I
certainly am ready for the cringe I've
been grabbed it ready for the cringe my
old goddamn life my old life has been a
cringefest so why would it be any
different let's go to it so we're back
on good old r/cringe this time instead
of going for the all-time cringe I'm
going to look up and laugh the cringe of
the last month do not believe that
glyphosate in Argentina is causing
increases in cancer you can drink a
whole quart of it and it won't hurt you
yes are you want to drink some we have
some here I'd be happy to actually yeah
not not really but not really I know it
wouldn't hurt me I'm not stupid
tell the truth it's not dangerous to
humans no no not so are you ready to
drink one glass of no I'm not an idiot
okay then except then the interview is
finished let's say that's a good way to
sell things yeah here at complete jerk
what a [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] do that
if someone's gonna call you out on your
[ __ ] then [ __ ] drink the water
you gotta commit fully to being an
[ __ ] or you're just even more of a
douchebag
didn't cringe though that's a [ __ ]
idiot yeah I'm going around
we got a new chance
alright guys you guys better enjoy the
show all right I'm trying
good lighting
what do you guys think does that make it
better
somewhat
didn't help at all already you think if
I drink this whole container it'll kill
me rigid all not cringy that's perfectly
normal and socially acceptable pager
okay Charlie I'm gonna sit here and just
hang out with my new best friend Athena
I think you see you two should get a
hotel room or something a lot of action
going on over there oh it's Charlie
probably the most action you've had in
months huh 69 degrees or today 69
degrees the expected high temperatures
easy I love that color that's such a
happy beautiful rich it almost kind of
looks like what the earth looks like
when you're a bazillion miles away from
the place yes I just are the Pineau the
moon is the planet daughter the Sun is a
star is the moon really a planet the
moon is a planet don't look at me like
that the Sun is a star is the Sun not a
star I don't know what the Sun is this
is a star the moon is not a planet you
were trying to take me down that road
wait moon is not a planet chunky if
you're listening tissues will build the
moon don't I guarantee you someone's
googling right now what else is it if
it's not a planet
I believe it's a star or something it's
so didn't you do that thing in grade
school where you had to name the planets
and there was Uranus it would be real
okay the moon is wet naturally the sad
lives on it as it's a planet I don't
know a satellite is anything that orbits
a planetoid I just want to ask you how
excited are you the very first think
boring world started it
yeah whoa there you go the crowd is on
fire as you can see
No oh my pussy's getting stretched
I did get him now okay for context cuz I
didn't say what this video was this is a
league streamer with his mom during a
very strenuous game oh my pussy's
getting stretched okay else's challenge
before I think this is what takes okay
this one's calls this cringe-worthy MLS
Chan makes us which football was never
invented witnessing the birth of a
dictator you can see the power that he
feels he's loving
[Applause]
oh boy oh wow
we witnessed someone in the midst of
going mad with power
you can see in his eyes after he said
every single time you can see in his
eyes of power just infusing in his mind
we've got all kinds of produce for you
to take home my squash Bears and
tomatoes that are locally grown our
markets got you covered with burgers and
rib eyes seafoods more your style
there's lots you can try if cheese is
your passion our selection is for real
we even if health and wellness are
important to you we have vitamins
protein bars and organic shampoo let's
break it down
coz we got a lot the first tortillas and
fresh pastry please tell me what could
be more exotic then motion-sensored
refrigerator buddy I got a copy for and
the Flex is pretty sweet can't go wrong
with gelato when you need a cold treat
you know I yeah I'm gonna have to do and
I have to do it a tactical withdrawal
from this video cuz I was just praising
what our people are better you can work
here and still be a trend setter
earrings goatee
fresh is a place where you can be you
took a dip it took a dip in the middle
event oh you know what it probably back
it brought it back and that's what's
important
that's what matters it brought it back I
did good and I'm proud of that and they
should be do Auto feel well so anyway
I'm pretty tired
Huntley enough that dancing kind of
wiped me out it wasn't very involved but
I think I'm gonna go take a nap so thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you enjoyed this drowned out - currents
challenge I lost a lot and then you lost
a lot because you were watching this
video and you saw our video from
yesterday which is already more Quincy
than any of the videos in here so thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
not talking about the 12 day of
christmas video
I want to believe part 2the believe
inning so um thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you everybody so
much for cringing and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye